j'avais conscience que ça pouvait être
dangereux ou pas du tout non pour vous
est peut-être pour l'essence et c'était
dangereux je ne sois pas d'accord
aujourd'hui ce que vous avez peur
peut-être d'avoir été contaminées ou non
ça ou pas du tout pas du tout pas du
tout vous vouliez gagner parce que si
demain les les chiffres de la coved
augmente à marseille à cause de ce cadre
elle est où vous allez vous sentir
coupable ou es ce que vous avez vous
dire non écoute roselyne bachelot avait
proposé de faire des concerts test alors
je veux être qu' il y en aura peut-être
que y en aura pas en tout cas donc là on
était six mille cinq cent suivant la
police alors dix mille suivant les
organisateurs d'accord donc du coup moi
ce que j'ai dit à tous les cas ce que
tous les manifestants qui étaient
présents là si jamais ils sont malades
qui se signalent
et comme ça on sera si effectivement le
virus a circulé mois si jamais je tombe
malade je dirais d'elle ce jeu d'arcade
et vous êtes tous pour les sanctionner
ladjimi alors l'argumentaire est
complètement catastrophique 1 de jack
wilshere un test grandeur nature je
rappelle qu'elle gens qui meurent de ce
genre de test hasardeuse que vous
proposez une chose est claire c'est que
le problème actuellement c'est la
vaccination c'est pas le carnaval en
vrai si on veut présenter les vrai
problème en france c'est la machine qui
va pas assez vite
est on en train de faire un tri à chenac
insupportable on vaccine les plus de 75
ans est en dessous de 75 ans il faut
avoir des pathologies extrêmement grave
un cancer ne suffit pas il faut avoir un
cancer non une chimiothérapie dans donc
ces cinq mois les en france c'est qu'on
va pas assez vite et qu'on n'ouvre pas
la vaccination et qu'on ne propose pas
correctement les vaccins ont un coût on
met astrazeneca c'est jacques a dit je
mets astra zeneca jacadi je l'aimé pas
65 ans 55 ans est confus en revanche je
comprends que vous en avez marre
moi aussi j'en ai marre les étudiants en
ont marre dans les ehpad ils ont marre
les restaurateurs on en a on en a tous
marre et on n'interdit pas les gens de
sortir dehors sortez dehors probablement
qu'à moins de risques durant le carnaval
que dans certaines écoles c'est vrai
qu'on parle les écoles de façon un peu
obscure on a l'impression qu'ils s'y
passe rien pour autant on le sait c'est
un moteur de l'épidémie mais il faut
laisser les écoles ouvertes
en revanche ce qu'on vous demande c'est
un minimum de cohérence si vous êtes
dehors porter un masque pas grand chose
qu'on vous demande un minimum de
distance mois quand j'en ai marre bah je
vais avec mes enfants je vais dans un
parc
je reste loin des gens je porte un
masque je limite le risque en revanche
quand on voit les images actuellement
l'asie mais à quoi ils jouent
est ce que vraiment vous respectez les
soignants qui à quelques kilomètres de
là ce monde et services de réanimation
galère depuis un an
ils en ont marre avec des gens qui
meurent tous les jours est ce que vous
pensez
leur faire honneur alors qu'on vous
demande pas grand-chose respecter des
gestes barrières mettre un masque et
temporiser et je les soigne pas il ya
des gens qui font des manifestations
toutes les semaines à paris faudrait
aussi les interdire si on pensait que
c'était risqué mais on vous demande un
masque à peu de distance
en revanche chanter crier danser collés
les uns sur les autres je pense que
malheureusement cette image n'est pas
acceptable en clochard est-ce que les
soignants été respectée avant le coup
vide est-ce qu'ils n'étaient pas déjà
surchargés de travail
là c'est dans leur tapez pas dessus
parce qu'il réclame et effectivement des
moyens supplémentaires
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit qu'ils en ont
besoin aujourd'hui ils deviennent des
héros
il ya un an peut-être que vous étiez
parmi les manifestants qui réclament y
ait un peu plus de moyens pour soigner
les gens
aujourd'hui on a notre système de santé
n'est pas adaptée ni aux kovy denis à ce
qui se passait à béchar vous avez quel
âge
une mécanique 54 ans ben vous êtes un
risque de formes graves de coronavirus
et c'est aussi en partie pour vous qu'on
s'est arrêté de vivre en quelque sorte
les plus jeunes se sont arrêtés de vivre
pour protéger les peuples alors on ne le
fait pas si c'est pour moi non ça va et
non mais c'est pas ces principes de
solidarité donc le minimum qu'on demande
aux gens c'est un peu de bon sens et
sortez dehors c'est possible mais le
masque et la distance s'était pas trop
demander à mons carnac